вже залічені дні ці пакунки відправлять
на фронт їх понад місяць усією країною
збирають для військових ЗСУ аби навіть в
бліндажі та окопи прийшло Різдво за цей
час у поштовому відділенні містечка
Полонне що на Хмельниччині роботи
додалося подарунки для українських
захисників щодня надходять
десятками кожні три дні ми стабільно
приїжджаємо на Нову пошту щоб забрати
подарунки стабільно ми отримуємо в
районі 30 пакунків але сьогодні
наприклад отримали 46
цього разу пакунків настільки багато що
в одну машину вони не помістилися тож
автівка знімальної групи ДВ теж стала в
пригоді з відділення пошти усі коробки
везуть на імпровізований склад спочатку
їх збирали в приватному будинку
волонтерів Утім дуже швидко там стало
тісно тепер подарунки для військових
зберігають в будівлі міськради тут їх
готують до відправки на
[музика]
фронт
майже в кожній коробці медикаменти
різноманітні знеболювальні та
протизастудні надсилають за запитом
військових але таємні Санти додають дещо
й від себе так це ліки а немісл ми
бачимо і
оскорбінка залом часто присилають ліки
якісь вітамінки так так дуже часто
хлопці замовляють певні ліки але ще я
бачу додають додаткові якісь вітамінки
смаколики загалом в рамках акції таємним
сантою для військових ЗСУ стали близько
5 000 українців серед основних Запитів
від воїнів зовсім не святкові а навпаки
буденні та суто воєнні речі ось приміром
український захисник замовив на Різдво
турнікети це турнікет це дуже класна річ
дуже потрібна нашим хлопцям і бачу ще
турнікети це їхнє життя в першу чергу це
їхнє життя Ну і звичайно повна коробка
смаколиків як це я не можу не
показатипер Тож кожен запит на подарунок
не примха а радше необхідність зараз
перш за все необхідні бушлати теплі
штани зимові берце тому що щоб не було
холодно грілки тобто все що може зігріти
зараз це необхідно звісно є якісь інші
речі там засоби гігієни якесь печиво
можуть люди покласти там листівку і так
далі це все збадьюрить але насправді в
пріоритеті ось цей теплий одяг який буде
гріти І хоча військові просять на Різдво
лише найнеобхідніше серед зібраних
подарунків є чимало книг та настільних
Ігор У такий спосіб українці турбуються
про дозвілля захисників О знову дівчата
книга Таємниця старого Лами
клас військові насправді такого не
просили але коли ми отримували пакунки і
відкривали їх то дуже-дуже-дуже багато
було таких подарунків де люди від себе
купували книги купували різні ігри і
докладали в подарунки та найзворушливіше
у кожному пакунку листи та дитячі
малюнки коли я читала я просто ну не
могла стримати сліз Я думаю що нашим
військовим буде надзвичайно
[музика]
приємно Дуже дякую що даєте нам
можливість жити коли ви
повернетесь а те падло здохне ми будемо
робити все можливе щоб ви себе комфортно
почували ви великі молодці Ми вас всіх
чекаємо додому Ми вас любимо ви
найкрутецькі запити на різдвяні
подарунки український Жіночий батальйон
збирав від військових і підрозділів
напряму ми працюємо виключно з
офіційними запитами і впродовж всієї
нашої діяльності у нас є перелік
військових або частин з якими ми
взаємодіємо ось і коли ми запускали цю
акцію ми написали їм якщо у вас є якась
пот треба яку ви хочете щоб ми закрили
то будь ласка дайте нам список Ось і
Власне вони формували Наразі у нас по
чеклисту 20 підрозділів і кожен з цих
підрозділів має від там 10 до 200-300
позицій усі запити сформовані в єдиний
довжелезний перелік як тільки на склад
привозять нову партію пакунків волонтери
одразу беруться за роботу адже кожен
подарунок має потрапити в потрібні руки
ми сортуємо іменно по цій людині в нас
стоять на кожній посилки циферки люди як
відправляють вони ставлять ці цифри для
кого іменно вона імена якби йдеться
поселках на сортування кожної нової
партії подарунків намагається знаходити
час пані Людмила для неї це не лише
можливість бути корисною для українських
захисників а й спосіб заспокоєння Адже
всі її найближчі чоловіки на війні в
мене чоловік військовий він з 14-го року
на фронті
так на сьогоднішній день він він теж в
зоні бойових дій в мене син з перших
днів війни теж був на фронті в мене зять
він теж з 14-го року на фронті це то що
я можу сказати особисто за себе Також
для того аби закрити усі потреби
військових український Жіночий батальйон
створив спеціальний збір завдяки
пожертвам небайдужих планують придбати
якісний теплий одяг який часом по
вартості непідйомний навіть для найбі б
небайдужих таємних Сант наприклад взуття
коштує одні берци хороші від 11 000
Тобто це одне взуття а їх треба там
пар60 там наприклад один костюм він
коштує 17 000 куртка низ коштує ще 10 це
насправді дорогий одяг але ми розуміємо
що він якісний усі подарунки на фронт
організатори акції обіцяють доставити
вчасно до Різдва яке цьогоріч Україна
офіційно святкуватиме 25
грудня